[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Camila Cabello has good reason to get
down the seniorita singer turned 23 in
good company on Tuesday Camila gave fans
a glimpse of the celebration in her
insta story and good boyfriend Shawn
Mendes was on hand for the big bash her
Cinderella director Kay cannon also
shared these photos from the parties
including this pic of the super happy
couple this is my best self
the former fifth harmony singer has been
in England shooting the fairytale
adaptation Camilla toe et about her
excitement for the film 2020 is gonna be
a big year for you because we also have
Cinderella to look forward to how
involved are you gonna be in the music
for that yeah super involved I'm writing
songs for it and it's like a really
collaborative effort to putting the
movie together so is that kind of insane
to know that you just put out an album
then we're gonna get more Camila
music because I'm excited about that I'm
so excited and Kay cannon is the
director she's absolutely incredible and
and so talented and just I think the
whole team is like it's such a joy so
I'm excited excited for the opportunity
it's really amazing
[Music]